THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DECIDE THE
FUTURE OF THIS COUNTRY.
TAKE A LISTEN.
JOINING US NOW IS SENATE
MAJORITY LEADER.
MITCH McCONNELL WITH US, HIS
MEMOIR IS ENTITLED "THE LONG
GAME," AND YOU FORWARD BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND NOW OUT ON
PAPERBACK.
WELCOME BACK TO THE PROGRAM.
I WANT TO FIND OUT ABOUT THE NEW
FORWARD.
I THINK MOST PEOPLE DON'T FULLY
UNDERSTAND -- LET'S ASSUME FOR A
MINUTE THAT THE HOUSE GOES
FORWARD WITH THIS IMPEACHMENT
AND ITS OVER TO THE SENATE.
WALK US THROUGH HOW THIS PROCESS
WORKS AND THE OPTIONS AVAILABLE
AND WHAT YOU SEE HAPPENING AND
HOW YOU SEE THIS GOING DOWN.
>> FIRST IS YOU POINTED IT OUT
TO YOUR VIEWERS, THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE BEEN WANTING TO DO THIS FOR
THREE YEARS.
FIRST HEADLINE IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" BEFORE THE
PRESIDENT WAS INAUGURATED THAT
THEY WERE GOING TO IMPEDE HIM.
THEY FINALLY GOT AROUND TO IT
AND WILL ASSUME THAT WE SEE TWO
ARTICLES IMPEACHMENT, PRETTY
WEAK STUFF COMING OVER TO US.
WHAT HAPPENS THEN?
UNDER THE RULES, HAS NO OPTION
TO TURN FROM IT AND THE SOLE
BUSINESS UNTIL WE FINISH.
HOW WE CAN IMPACT THAT REALLY IS
WITH JUST 51 VOTES, THE CHIEF
JUSTICE IS WITHIN THE CHAIR AND
I DON'T EXPECT THE CHIEF JUSTICE
TO TRY TO TILT THE PLAYING FIELD
EITHER WAY.
WE WILL LISTEN TO THE OPENING
ARGUMENTS BY THE HOUSE
PROSECUTORS.
WE WILL LISTEN TO THE
PRESIDENT'S LAWYERS RESPOND.
AND THEN WE'LL HAVE TO MAKE A
DECISION ABOUT THE WAY FORWARD.
EVERYTHING I DO, COORDINATING
WITH WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL PER
THERE'LL BE NO DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT'S POSITION
AND OUR POSITION AS TO HOW TO
HANDLE THIS.
TO THE EXTENT THAT WE CAN BUT WE
DO NOT HAVE THE KIND OF BALL
CONTROL WHERE A TYPICAL ISSUE
WILL COME TO THE HOUSE, IF WE
DON'T LIKE IT WE WILL TAKE IT
UP.
WE HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO TAKE IT
WE'LL WORK THIS PROCESS IN A
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME IN TOTAL
COORDINATION WITH THE
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL'S OFFICE AND
THE PEOPLE REPRESENTING THE
PRESIDENT.
>> Sean: I'VE GOT TO BELIEVE
THE FEDERAL RULES FOR THE
ADMISSION OF EVIDENCE WOULD
APPLY HERE WITH THE CHIEF
JUSTICE IN CHARGE, THAT WOULD
MEAN THERE WOULD BE NO HEARSAY
EVIDENCE BE ALLOWED, THAT WOULD
PROBABLY MEAN, WELL, YOU MIGHT
HAVE ONE OR TWO OPINION PEOPLE,
FACT EXPERTS.
BUT WHEN WE WATCH THIS PROCESS
UNFOLD IN THE HOUSE, ESPECIALLY
IN THE SCHIFF SHOW, EVERYBODY
WAS HEARSAY OR OPINION WITNESS.
THE ONE FACT WITNESS SAID, THE
PRESIDENT SAID HE WANTED
NOTHING, NO QUID PRO QUO.
THAT WAS THE ONLY FACT WITH THIS
THAT I SAW A PAIR THAT WOULD BE
AMBASSADOR SONDLAND.
WITH THAT BE IN YOUR VIEW HOW
THE FEDERAL RULES OF EVIDENCE
APPLY HERE?
>> EXACTLY HOW WE GO FORWARD I
WILL COORDINATE WITH THE
PRESIDENT'S LAWYERS, THEY WOULD
BE NO DIFFERENCE BETWEEN US ON
HOW TO DO THIS.
YOU RAISE THE ISSUE ON WHAT IF
YOU HAVE WITNESSES MUCH LIKE THE
PRESIDENT OF PROSSER'S COUNSEL
MAY OR MAY NOT DECIDE THEY WANT
TO HAVE WITNESSES.
THE CASE IS SO WEAK.
WE KNOW HOW IT'S GOING TO END.
NOPE CHANCE THE PRESIDENT IS
GOING TO BE REMOVED FROM OFFICE
BUT MY HOPE IS THERE WILL BE NO
SINGLE REPUBLICAN WHO VOTES FOR
EITHER OF THESE ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT.
SEAN, IT WOULDN'T SURPRISE ME IF
WE GOT ONE OR TWO DEMOCRATS.
IT LOOKS TO ME OVER AT THE HOUSE
THE REPUBLICANS SEEM TO BE SOLID
AND THE DEMOCRATS SEEM TO BE
DIVIDED.
>> I THINK YOU RIGHTLY POINT
OUT, THIS IS VERY WEAK.
WE LOOK FOR EXAMPLE AT THE
OBSTRUCTION ISSUE.
HERE, THE PRESIDENT LIKE EVERY
OTHER PAST PRESIDENT HAS EXERTED
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
THEY DON'T LIKE IT WHEN THERE IS
A DISPUTE BETWEEN THE SECOND OF
BRANCH AND THE LEGISLATIVE
BRANCH, THAT WOULD BE TO THE
ROLE OF THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
WHICH IS TO RESOLVE THE DISPUTES
BETWEEN THE OTHER TWO BRANCHES
OF GOVERNMENT BUT FRANKLY THEY
ARE IN SUCH A RUSH TO DO THIS
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO GIVE THE
COURTS ANY TIME OR WORSE THEY
FEARED WHAT THE COURTS WOULD
DECIDE.
>> Sean:
>> Tean:
>> THIn:
>> THIS:
>> THIS IS A THOROUGHLY
POLITICAL EXERCISE.
IT'S NOT A COURTROOM EXPERIENCE.
IT'S A POLITICAL EXPERIENCE.
THEY'VE GONE AND SCREWED UP THE
COURAGE TO DO IT.
IT LOOKS TO ME THAT IT MAY BE
BACKFIRING ON THEM VERTICALLY
AND SWING DISTRICTS THAT THE
SPEAKER'S PARTY MANAGED WIN.
MOST OF THE NERVOUSNESS I SEE ON
THIS ISSUE WITH POLITICIANS
SINCE THE POLITICAL PROCESS IS
ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE.
>> Sean: ASSUME HE COMES OVER
TO THE SENATE.
YOU ARE OBLIGATED TO TAKE IT UP.
EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS THAT.
WHOEVER THE HOUSE CHOOSES TO
PRESENT THE CASE, THEY WILL
PRESENT THEIR CASE.
HOWEVER LONG PERIOD OF TIME THAT
TAKES.
I COULD PROBABLY BE PERSUADED ON
EITHER SIDE, WHICH FOR ME IS A
RARE THING, SENATOR, AND THAT
WOULD BE OKAY.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WOULD LIKE TO
BRING IN ADAM SCHIFF, HUNTER
BIDEN, JOE BIDEN.
I THINK I'M MORE INCLINED TO
AGREE WITH SENATOR GRAHAM ON
THIS.
IT'S TEMPTING, AND THEY DO
BELIEVE THAT ALL OF THESE THINGS
MUST BE LOOKED INTO PER THERE
ARE A LOT OF REAL QUESTIONS
HERE.
BUT I DON'T KNOW IF THAT WOULD
BE THE APPROPRIATE FORUM ONCE
YOU HAVE THE 51 VOTES TO END
THIS, VERY WEAK CASE BUT I THINK
IT WOULD BE SMART TO DO SO.
WHERE WOULD YOUR INCLINATION BE
>> I'M GOING TO TAKE MY CUES
FROM THE PRESIDENT'S LAWYERS.
IF YOU KNOW YOU HAVE THE VOTE,
LISTEN TO THE ARGUMENTS ON BOTH
SIDES, AND BELIEVE THE CASE IS
SO SLIM, SO WEAK THAT YOU HAVE
THE VOTES TO END IT, THAT MIGHT
BE WHAT THE PRESIDENT'S LAWYERS
WOULD PREFER, AND YOU COULD
CERTAINLY MAKE THE CASE FOR
MAKING IT SHORTER RATHER THAN
LONGER SINCE IT'S SUCH A WEAK
CASE.
>> ARE YOU CONFIDENT -- WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT FOR EXAMPLE THE
OBSTRUCTION CHARGE AND THE OTHER
WOULD BE THE ABUSE OF POWER
CHARGE.
YOU READ THE PHONE CALL.
YOU WATCH, I'M SURE, A LOT OF
THE COVERAGE THAT HAS TAKEN
PLACE IN THE HOUSE.
DO YOU SEE ANY EVIDENCE OF ANY
WRONGDOING WHATSOEVER ON THE
PRESIDENT'S PART AS YOU READ THE
TRANSCRIPT, I READ IT OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
I CERTAINLY DON'T SEE WHAT WE
HEAR JOE BIDEN BRAGGING ABOUT.
YOU ARE NOT GETTING A BILLION
TAXPAYER DOLLARS UNLESS YOU ARE
A PROSECUTOR INVEST GETTING HIS
SON WITH ZERO EXPERIENCE MAKING
MILLIONS.
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
>> THIS IS A REALLY WEAK CASE
AND THAT'S WHY I THINK YOU ARE
GOING TO SEE BIPARTISAN
OPPOSITION TO THE ARTICLES OVER
IN THE HOUSE.
>> Sean: HOW LONG ARE YOU
THINKING AND WE WILL MOVE ON
FROM HERE, HOW LONG DO YOU
IMAGINE AFTER THE HOUSE PRESENTS
ITS CASE, THAT WILL HAPPEN IN
FOLD --
>> IF THEY DO THIS NEXT WEEK,
SEAN, WE WILL BE ABLE TO HAVE TO
GO OVER CHRISTMAS BUT WE WILL
TURN ABOUT IT RIGHT AROUND THE
FIRST OF THE YEAR AND WE WOULD
STAY ON THAT UNTIL WE FINISH.
MY HOPE IS THAT IT WILL BE A
SHORTER PROCESS RATHER THAN A
LONG, LENGTHY PROCESS.
>> YOU HAVE YOUR BOOK AND --
LOOK, DONALD TRUMP IS A LOT OF
THINGS AND I'VE KNOWN HIM
PROBABLY LONGER THAN YOU, WELL
OVER 20 SOMETHING ODD YEARS.
HE'S DISRUPTIVE.
HE'S AN ICONOCLAST.
HE'S A FIGHTER.
HE'S GOT A LOT OF GOOD THINGS
DONE FOR THE COUNTRY.
KEPT A LOT OF PROMISES WITH YOUR
HELP ON JUDGES, TAX CUTS,
CERTAINLY HE'S GOT THE MONEY FOR
THE WALL, ENDING BURDENSOME
REGULATION FROM A BITTER TRADE
DEALS.
THE ALBA GOT A CALIPHATE
DEFEATED.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW NOW WHAT THIS
PRESIDENT THREE YEARS THAT YOU
DIDN'T KNOW?
>> LET ME TELL YOU WHAT THIS
BOOK IS ABOUT.
THE BOOK IS ABOUT THE MOST
LONG-LASTING OBSERVATION THAT
DONALD TRUMP AND THE SENATE
BECOME THE
REPUBLICANS FOR THE COUNTRY END.
PUTTING YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN WHO
ARE STRICKEN STRUCTURALISTS
WHOSE JOBS ARE TO FOLLOW THE LAW
IN THE COURTS.
WE DID OUR 50TH CIRCUIT COURT
JUDGE JUST YESTERDAY.
TO PUT THAT IN PERSPECTIVE,
BARACK OBAMA DID 55 CIRCUIT
JUDGES IN A COKE YEARS.
WE DID 50 IN THREE YEARS.
AND WE HAVE A YEAR LESS FOR
SURE.
WE ARE GOING TO DO ONE FOURTH OF
THE CIRCUIT JUDGES.
MOST CASES DID NOT MAKE IT TO
THE SUPREME COURT PROMOTES
COMPLEX LITIGATION NEVER MAKES
IT BEYOND THE CIRCUIT COURTS
COURTS.
THIS HAS BEEN THE MOST
LONG-LASTING CONJUGATION THE
PRESIDENT COULD MAKE IN THE
FUTURE, FAR BEYOND HIS TENURE IN
OFFICE.
WE'LL HAVE A JUDICIARY NOT TO
MAKE IT UP ON THE FLY.
OBAMA SAID HE WANTED TO APPOINT
JUDGES WHO HAD EMPATHY.
THAT MAKES GREAT SENSE IF YOU
ARE A LYTIC KIT BEFORE THE JUDGE
BEFORE WHOM THE JUDGE HAS
EMPATHY, NOT SO GOOD IF YOU ARE
NOT.
>> Sean: LET'S SAY SOMEBODY
WERE TO RETIRE AT THE END OF
THIS YEAR, LEADING INTO THE
SUMMER.
YOU HAVE BEEN VERY CLEAR IF THE
PRESIDENT HAD SUPPORTED
SOMEBODY, YOU WOULD FOLLOW
THROUGH ON THAT NOMINATION.
>> WE DEFINITELY WOULD DO THAT.
AND THIS PAPERBACK WE WERE JUST
TALKING ABOUT, THE PRESIDENT'S
FORWARD IS ABOUT JUDGES, THE
AFTERWORD CATCHES US UP WHAT'S
HAPPENED WITH THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION ON JUDGES BECAUSE
MY MEMOIR CAME OUT THREE YEARS
AGO BEFORE THE PRESIDENT WAS
ELECTED.
WHAT WE DID HERE, THE PRESIDENT
AND I DID WITH THIS PAPERBACK
THAT HE WAS SHOWING ON THE
SCREEN, TALK ABOUT HOW THE JUDGE
PROJECT CAME ABOUT, HOW IT WENT
FORWARD.
IF YOU RECALLED, SEAN, THE MOST
IMPORTANT DECISION I MADE IN MY
ENTIRE POLITICAL CAREER WAS TO
NOT FILL THE SUPREME COURT
VACANCY WHEN JUSTICE SCALIA
PASSED AWAY.
THAT WAS THE BEGINNING AND WE
HAVE THE EXCLAMATION POINT HERE
THREE YEARS THE PUBLIC WOULD BE
INTERESTED TO READ ABOUT, THAT'S
WHY THE PRESIDENT AND I
COLLABORATED ON THIS PAPERBACK.
>> Sean: I WAS SURPRISED
PRESIDENT OBAMA LEFT SO MANY
VACANCIES AND DIDN'T FILL THOSE
VACANCIES.
>> I WILL TELL YOU WHY, I WAS IN
CHARGE OF WHAT WE DID THE LAST
TWO YEARS OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Sean: I WILL GIVE YOU FULL
CREDIT FOR THAT AND TAKE A BOW.
CONGRATULATIONS ON THE BOAT.
WE WILL BE WATCHING VERY CLOSELY
IN THE SENATE.
DO YOU SEE ANY POSSIBLE
AFFECTIONS?
>> I DOUBT IT.
THERE IS ZERO CHANCE THE